[Música]
muito voltado a todos antes de mais
muito obrigada por esta conexão sinto a
desde o primeiro momento aqui até em
cabelos e sinto no coração muito
obrigado é uma honra estar cá meu nome é
com foi apresentado paulo barbosa
sou aquilo que eu posso dizer um tipo de
viagem enquanto em algumas livrarias não
muitas porque tem muitas poças
considerado idiota mas facto tem algumas
idéias e tenho também algumas teorias
uma dessas teorias que eu chamo claussen
do gapz é aquela que vai apresentar cá
hoje esta teoria é tão importante para
mim que eu não tomou nenhuma decisão
profissional saem por a prova se esta
teoria do fato está correta ou não eu
vou te apresentar esta teoria
esta teoria tem como pressuposto os 15
sempre é tecnologia avança e está um
princípio fundamental a tecnologia está
constantemente a avançar proibida
ela vai fazer algo com que exista no
espaço que é um espaço fosse um gato ou
seja a tecnologia permite nos perceber
que há alguma coisa por preencher este
espaço precisa de facto de ser
preenchido
vamos vamos dar um exemplo muito claro
que isto jamais o que aconteceu na
música e mais em concreto na música
digital
houve um conjunto tipos que se uniam
quatro vezes por ano e que tinham como
dilma resolver algo que tem a ver com a
música analógica para digital e depois o
digital para um formato mais comprimido
e eles discutiram tanto que chegaram à
conclusão conseguiam fazer uma
composição da música para ela ocupar dez
vezes menos um espaço ou seja a música
que nós tínhamos no nosso seria seria
possível ser armazenadas no nosso
computador ocupando desde crianças - o
espaço do fischer original e mais esta
perda desta corrupção não envolve uma
perda de qualidade
pelo menos que fosse perceptível para o
fito
ano ou seja nós conseguiríamos ter muita
música dentro dos nossos computadores e
isto realmente foi um grande avanço
tecnológico mudou a nossa relação com a
música
passámos a ter um conjunto livrarias de
playlists nossos computadores muito
maior do que a que tínhamos armazenados
os nossos cds e esta relação com música
deixou na altura bastante contentes
porque nós conseguimos factos gigas
gigas gigas de música
conseguimos ouvir toda a música crime e
conseguimos fazer outra coisa fantástica
que era eu consigo saltar da música pra
música ver numa fração de segundo que eu
desse dia que eu queria ouvir
contudo este avanço tecnológico fez com
que houvesse aqui uma gata um espaço
para preencher um espaço que alguém
antes do tempo percebeu e conseguiu
perceber que conseguir colocar aqui algo
que as pessoas iriam querer no futuro ou
seja essa fase técnicos o tecnológico
fez com que as pessoas passassem muito
tempo presa já o seu computador portanto
era fantástico vimos toda essa música
mas o preço a pagar era que nós teríamos
que está agarrado ao computador não
conseguiríamos levar a nossa música como
nós não conseguimos sair com a música
para fora para colhermos para faltarmos
para brincar no jogo para andar de
bicicleta
alguém viu isto alguém percebeu que esta
necessidade que este espaço propunha
cheiro estava cá e não foi isso foi esta
antes do tempo pensou eu vou preencher
este espaço e ao preencher da melhor
forma possível
lançou um equipamento que foi realmente
revolucionar tudo aquilo que esta
empresa tenha feito e essa empresa não
era uma empresa que estava propriamente
no mundo da música
não era uma só não era uma phillips era
uma empresa que fazia computadores e aos
mais do que ninguém perceberam que
quando colocaram este dispositivo
conseguiram realmente ocupar um espaço
esta metáfora para explicar no fundo da
minha teoria é para tentarmos perceber o
papel com conseguimos realmente utilizar
a nossa antecipação para perceber os
passos que estão por preencher quando a
tecnologia avança e ou em determinada
altura percebi algo que estava
acontecendo
os consumidores estavam a mudar
rapidamente o comportamento ou seja e
externa muito traumático para as marcas
para as empresas pretendem estabelecer
negócios com os consumidores e as
empresas
as marcas precisam de saber que os
recursos consumidos estão a fazer é que
os normalmente estão quais são seus
jatos dos quais são as suas práticas e
as marcas que ainda achavam que os
consumidores estavam todos sentados à
mesma hora enfrenta o mesmo dispositivo
haver o mesmo canal provisão ao
movimento estavam completamente fora do
jogo porque as marcas têm que perceber
rapidamente as pessoas tentavam mudar
comportamentos e mudar hábitos das
pessoas estavam a consumir algo que não
existia anteriormente que era redes
sociais social media ou seja passavam
muito tempo a consumir um novo produto
que não existia quando essas marcas se
observamos lançaram mas mais do que isto
também perceberam que as pessoas
escolhiam o que queriam ver
ou seja não era apenas uma questão de
receber aquilo que está a ser emitido é
eu ir à procura daquilo que eu quero ver
eu escolhi o conteúdo podendo visualizar
e outra coisa também estava acontecendo
nessa altura era que não era apenas uma
questão de um único dispositivo
tratava se de muitos múltiplos
dispositivos ou seja é vegetal andef
smartphones via computador já havia um
conjunto novas coisas que as pessoas
tinham na mão que anteriormente não
acontecia então as marcas e antes disso
também há uma outra questão é que mesmo
aquelas pessoas que têm um comportamento
mais estabilizado mais estudado que não
propriamente seriam os primeiros
habitantes da tecnologia estavam a usar
a tecnologia estávamos aula também com
muito rigor
eu posso dizer que a minha mãe que
utiliza mais o facebook do que eu
é importante esta mudança do
comportamento acontece num curto espaço
de tempo isto chegou à conclusão do que
realmente os consumidores estavam entrar
em novos territórios e as marcas não
estavam o presidente manda que ele
estava estava a ser uma situação tinha
que ser rapidamente resolvida
o gato número 2 que eu consegui
encontrar é que realmente as marcas
precisam se adaptar que conquistaram os
consumidores estão dando é impossível
uma marca estava comunicar no canal onde
o consumidor já lá não está vazio e se
esse canal estava vazio as marcas
estavam simplesmente a fazer uma
comunicação que não estava completamente
acordo com o comportamento dos
consumidores e os consumidores também
precisam que as marcas saíram adaptar
para as suas próprias mudanças de
comportamento se uma marca não souberam
comunicar no canal uno um novo
consumidor está essa marca está
aprendendo um potencial gigante com essa
é sim esse canal e aos consumidores
tanto nós temos ali qualquer coisa que
eles não se conseguem ver cinco shannon
que é precisamente aquilo que estava a
acontecer antes desta função todo aquilo
que nós assistimos que é a relação de
uma loja física com o consumidor e essa
relação pode continuar a existir mas
está provavelmente condenada a ter um
grau de fracasso muito elevado porque
alguns alguém vai estar a fazer o mesmo
noutros canais muito mais barato e muito
mais rápido
tanto a idéia de que nós podemos ter uma
única estratégia uma estratégia de
single xano para um consumidor está
completamente ultrapassada se
percebermos que temos todos estes canais
que podemos estar a ser utilizados pelos
nossos consumidores
outra coisa também verifica é que dada a
multiplicidade de tantos dispositivos
era normal que as pessoas queiram ter
experiências muito muito muito próximas
cada um desses canais ou seja eu não
posso comunicar
da mesma forma e no mobile num
smartphone ou até mesmo numa comunicação
que faço via e mel com mesma forma que
faço através da loja física tomar 11 eps
ao normal
nós temos que receber esse novo conceito
que existe e se chama homem chama este
conceito é muito muito muito importantes
nos dias de hoje
agora significa que nós temos que saber
envolvem os nossos clientes envolver os
nossos consumidores italianos é melhor
experiência em cada um dos penais em que
está em contacto connosco não se trata
apenas de colocar lá a nossa informação
é perceber qual é o canal e qual é a
melhor forma de envolvermos cuidarmos
melhor experiência possível para e eu
consegui estar tendo descansado e eu sei
que escolhe os canais deixamos de ser
lógico e aquilo que eu consegui perceber
foi se lançássemos uma plataforma que
permite sair às empresas
acho os pequenos negócios qualquer
business que fosse lançado que
indiretamente esta capacidade está em
multicanais e criar é melhor experiência
para o consumidor em cada um desses
canais é entre ambos realmente qualquer
coisa officer ao mercado
deixemos montarmos uma pequena história
dentro desta desta longa jornada que
tenho vivido
temos muitos muitos exemplos muitas
histórias para contar
muitos que estão antes muitas coisas que
seriam de um enorme prazer poder voar
com vocês mas há uma que realmente
quando arrancámos fez com que eu
percebesse que nós tínhamos acertado em
alguma coisa
o antônio cuco era um professor um
professor que estava sempre carro que é
uma coisa que em portugal acontece com
alguma frequência os professores têm uma
tendência a ficar desempregados com o
cão com bastante freqüência e viu nessa
situação
viu se uma situação que estava
desempregado mas que tinha algo que não
sonho queria realmente montar esse sonho
era criar o primeiro do fim português
eu tinha essa essa capacidade de engenho
têm essa vontade quem essa intenção mas
faltava algo fundamental que é o fundos
necessários para poder arrancar com o
negócio o que o fez foi realmente altos
tendem foi brilhante fantástico
ela criou uma página no facebook espera
esta estão produtos dela atualmente na
altura que eu não tinha sequer o produto
e ela abriu uma página no facebook e fez
qualquer coisa como criar uma comunidade
é que eu dizia eu vou produzir o
primeiro chip português e vou produzir
daqui a três meses
mas vou colocá-lo à venda hoje
e se vocês não comprarem o new team hoje
vai ser entregue daqui a três meses
vocês vão ser meus sócios vitalícios da
minha marca e vão receber um desconto
para sempre todas as compras que fizeram
do meu produto
e nessa noite o antônio cuco vendeu 300
garrafas do sharing 5 sair produzido
havia três meses e conseguiu os fundos
necessários para conseguir arrancar com
a sua promoção
isto aconteceu porque utilizam a
plataforma que lhe permitiu estar a
comunicar com os no canal um dos seus
consumidores um dos seus seguidores
estavam a comunicar com ele
isto na minha opinião foi fazer um close
de gato
[Aplausos]